This video is made possible by Vince.
Sarah watches luxury handcrafted watchers,
but at fair prices,
you can check them out of
INSERRA watches.com forward
slash buyer graphics more
on them in a bit.
Yeah.
During the 13th century and merchants
named Marco Polo returns home to Italy
after spending 24 years living
in the Mongolian empire,
he had the bad luck of getting arrested
in Genoa while they were at war with his
hometown of Venice.
He was a prisoner for two years and he
just happened to share his cell with a
famous writer named [inaudible] Piza.
The two of them shared
stories with one another.
As you do when you're stuck in a
prison cell with absolutely no form of
entertainment.
Rista Jello was so captivated by the
stories of Markopolos Jannie this he knew
that it would make a great book.
So they spent those two years in
captivity writing the manuscript together.
When they were released from prison,
they published the travels
of Marco Polo Mens.
It became an overnight best seller.
Marco Polo became the first
Europeans in documents.
So many details about the
Mongolian and Chinese empires.
The Western world had a difficult time
believing that it was possible that there
could be a civilization now there that
was actually more advanced than theirs is
stories.
They were so fantastic that people assumed
that it was a work of fiction for the
rest of his life. Marco
Polo, he was called a liar.
It would take hundreds of years before
the world would know that every single
story he told was absolutely true and yes,
even today,
there are some skeptics who find it hard
to believe that one man could have seen
and done so much in his lifetime,
but he has still gone down in history as
being one of the greatest explorers in
the world.
Marco Polo was born into a wealthy
Venetian family in the year 1254 it was
expected to follow the family trade
of becoming a merchant's. His father,
Niccolo and his uncle mafia were
traveling most of Marco's young life.
I like a normal job. Merchants
were expected to leave
home for years at a time.
They traveled the world as they
gathered popular items like spices,
pals and goals and gemstones that
were plentiful in certain countries.
They then sold these goods in other
countries where they were more valuable.
They would earn enough money to last for
years and then again set out on a new
journey,
but that's how I'm travelers would return
to Europe claiming that they had seen
amazing creatures in the Far East.
Many of these,
they weren't complete works of fiction.
There were stories about a
country full of human dog hybrids,
fire breathing dragons,
and mystical unicorns.
Christians believes that the garden of
Eden was somewhere the hemorrhaging in
the Middle East and Jerusalem was
located in the exact center of the world.
A lot of people either fully believed
these fairy tales or trays to take
everything with a grain of salt.
There any people who knew the truth
about what when's on in foreign countries
were the ones who had seen these places
with their own eyes at a time when
traveling man going on a journey that
requires ceiling walking or horseback
riding. People could only go so far before
they ran out of money, food, and water.
So the only people who really
traveled the world with the merchants,
they had generations of the family's maps
and personal experiences behind them.
It took an entire lifetime
to write half of the journey.
Marco Polo grew up learning to read,
write,
and speak multiple languages while
his father and uncle were gone.
His mother passed away and he
spends a lot of his time at home,
eagerly waiting for his father and uncles
to return so that they could go on an
adventure together. By the
time Nickelodeon's, Matthew
finally resigned to Venice.
Marco Polo was 15 years old.
They told the boy that they had spent
several years in Constantinople before
finding themselves ushered into China.
At the heart of the Mongolian empire,
the leader could Bly.
Khan was interested in meeting them
because they'd never seen European men
before.
The con was impressed by their ability
to read and write in so many languages
and he believed that they
could be very useful to him.
The Polo brothers were treated as esteemed
guests and they were given luxuries
beyond their wildest dreams.
He asked them to resend to Italy
on a mission to meet with the pope,
could blown colon had requested for the
Podo brothers to bring back 100 priests.
The Mongolian Empire.
Kublai Khan was a Buddhist,
but he was very accepting of
all cultures and religions.
He wants to Christians to come into
his empire to help diversify academic
knowledge of the kingdom.
Unfortunately for the Polos,
they returned to find that the Vatican
was arguing over who would become the
next pope.
Niccolo Ans Mofo brought back golden
gemstones there were hidden in the lining
of their clothes and they were able to
sell them for a small fortune for two
years.
They prepare tax returns,
Mongolia and taught Marco all about
what to expect on the journey.
Without the help of the pipe,
they could only convince to
priests to come with them.
When Marco was 17 his father and uncle
packed up the caravan and so they set off
on a journey across the lands that
would take them a full three years.
Traveling from Italy to
China was no small task.
The polos had plans to take a boat there,
but they realize this
after years of being away,
the families share but fallen
into disrepair and that
would be no way for them
to sail.
They had no choice but to go on foot.
If they went straight through the desert,
they would never make it so
they had to go on a journey.
Where they were able to stop at small
cities and OAC is along the way.
They would have taken camels, horses
and donkeys to help carry the supplies.
They aged dried meat and drank water
and once they reached a town or city,
they would barter with their goods to
trade for fresh fruits and vegetables in
the marketplaces.
All along the way,
they carried goods that they could
sell for a profit in the next country.
The journey would have been exhausting
and they would have been exposed to
brutal elements,
but there were also countless numbers of
bandits waiting to steal from traveling
caravans. Marco Polo matches the Tata
who are known to kill men without mercy,
but the Polo family was gifted with
golden passports which provided them
protection from the great con.
It was written this,
if anyone were to mess with the Polos,
they would have to face the
wrath of comms and tire.
Army because of this he never mentioned
is going through many hardships during
that journey except for the
fact that the two priests,
somebody couldn't handle it.
They were forced to turn back and returned
to a city department is not to cross
over the permia mountains
in South Central Asia.
He describes the basic colds and tell
that funds were never as hard as they were
back home.
The next big challenge was the Gobi
desert where they periodically came across
the scatter dozens of dead animals and
humans who had not survive the harsh
conditions.
He often heard the singing sand dunes.
He described as just sounding
like different instruments
playing all at once and
sometimes it sounded like the
dunes where we're spring, his name,
it was enough to drive a mad Matt.
There was stories of men wandering into
the desert to try and find the source of
the music, but they never
returns. Now this story,
Trudy does sound supernatural because
it was as if some vengeful spirit was
trying to love men into the deserts, but
this is actually a very real phenomenon.
These musical notes come from the sounds
of vibrations of sen sliding down the
dunes that play the musical notes,
g e orF ,
which some people have described
as sounding similar to a cello.
Once market Podo reached China,
he became very ill and was afraid
that he might actually die,
but he founds mountains that were said
to have magical healing powers and he
climbs the mountain, breathe in the fresh
and ruins founds. Trudy did heal him.
He read that into batch.
Parents wanted their daughters to have
sex with as many men as possible before
they got married so that they could prove
how desirable they would be as wives
as he was a young European men.
These patterns where practically throwing
their daughters at mt have a foreigner
review.
That daughter's sexual
abilities he mentioned is that
Tibet was a great place to
be for a boy who was 70 to 20 years olds.
Of course,
this story goes to a bit of controversy
and it was one of the many examples of
the stories that people found is
too far fetched to believe bus.
It is actually based on a real custom.
Now,
just before we get into the second topic,
today's video,
let me tell you a bit about Vince.
Sarah watches,
I'm wearing one of these
watches right now. This is,
I've been Sarah chronic off as
well as keeping perfect time.
It's also got a timer and these three
back doll's hair that ain't just look
great.
They also serve that time a function.
Now I picked out a watch from the area
with a blue and silver combination,
but there are loads of different
options on their website.
You're sure to find something that suits
your style and also they'll accommodate
your risk size.
I have small wrists a say.
They managed to get me a smaller watch,
which is fantastic. It fits great on me.
Now.
I've put this watch through its paces
and it's still looking as good as the day
I got it. Super durable. The watch
itself also, if the leather strap,
in fact the leather
strap doesn't look new,
it kind of has that nice age leather look.
It gets a little bit softer,
a little bit better. I really
like that Nevin. Sarah watches.
They believe that luxury isn't
about price, so specification,
it's about detail and craftsmanship
and Vin. Zara watches.
They've got a ton of that.
Unlike many other watches on the market,
this isn't about minimalist style. You've
seen those watches. This isn't that.
It's more about the classic look of a
good watch further by selling direct to
the consumer of INSERRA can deliver a
great watch for a much better price than
you might expect.
Go check out the full
range@thansarahwatches.com
forward slash and biographics
and use the code biographics on
checkouts for a special discounts.
Thanks to Sarah Watches for
sponsoring and let's get back to it.
Years Before Marco Polo
was born, a powerful leader
named to Gingiss con United,
the Mongolian Empire. Once all of the
Mongol tribes were led by a single leader,
they began to conquer surrounding
territories in Asia, eastern Europe,
and the Middle East.
Mongolian worriers what trains since
they were toddlers to ride on horseback.
As the men's spends their entire
lives preparing her vassal,
they simply had the strongest army in
the world with millions of soldiers
prepared to fight for the con.
In each new generation,
the strongest dad was chosen to be the
new con Malkai Podo and his family.
They were keen to see Kublai Khan,
who was arguably one of the greatest
rulers the empire had ever seen off to
traveling or the 10,000 miles.
Marco Knicker, Loewen's mafia,
polo all arrived Kublai Khan,
some a palace.
They were all greeted as
esteemed royal guests.
Even though he had heard so many
stories from his father and uncle,
it could never compare to
experiencing the real thing.
Marco Polo was completely blown away
by the wealth and magnificence of the
Mongolian empire.
The palace was massive and it had its
own park with lush gardens and exotic
species of animals living on the lands.
Even in the 12 hundreds the Chinese had
advanced systems of heating and cooling.
This had never seen in
Europe pipes in the ground.
He took the polished hardwood floors,
which captured the royal court warm and
the winds are engineers have constructed
impressive buildings and bridges.
Further vet sanitation systems
were also years ahead of Europe.
Everyone was clean,
they smell good,
and they dressed in luxurious silk
robes shimmering with golden threats.
For Marco Polo, it was like he has
simply died and gone to happen.
The colon through a celebration
for the Polo family's arrival,
and then they had a huge feast.
They fetch over 40,000 guests and Marco
Polo could fill this cup with unlimited
drinks from a massive
silver wine fountain.
He was incredibly impressed with Kublai
Khan polo look time to him with an
almost godlike reverends because it
was an example of the perfect ruler.
The grade column has incredible skill
and battle like his ancestors before him,
but he was also educated and level
headed when it came to making diplomatic
decisions. Instead of attempting to rule
every single country that he conquered,
Kublai Khan allowed existing government
structures to continue functioning on
their own,
so long as they agreed to bow down to
the con and pledged their allegiance to
the Mongolian empire.
This means that every territory was
allowed to keep their religions,
their languages, and their culture.
Kublai Khan, he's celebrated diversity,
and he believes that one day the Mongolian
empire would spread across the entire
planet.
Because of this,
it was very important to have advisors
like Podo family and his courts to help
him negotiate with foreign nations.
Marco Polo became one of Kubler icons,
trusted advisors,
and he was able to live among the
royal court since he could speak five
languages. He was very useful
in diplomacy and negotiations.
He was eventually trusted to be in
charge of the Mongolian salt straightens
broker deals for sending the minerals
to other lands at that time. Salts.
It was incredibly valuable even though
it was relatively easy to produce.
He described in great detail about how
the workers made sold from boiling sea
water in giant Vats,
which is a technique that is
still used in China today.
Along with all of these responsibilities,
Marco Polo was announced to enjoy all of
the best entertainment that the empire
to offer. There were musical
performances, horse races,
this Aaron's wrestling matches.
Men of high standing were allowed
to have their own harm as well.
The most beautiful women in the
empire were all brought to the palace.
He wrote about how for women were skilled
and playing musical instruments and
how they were all graceful and polite.
Keep in minds that he was just 20 years
old when he arrived and he had already
had so much experience being the most
popular guy in Tibet during his journey to
China.
While it's not included in his book,
there is one Chinese court record from
that time that is believed to be about
Marco Polo.
A foreign man was arrested because he
was walking with a woman alone at night
without an escort.
This was illegal,
but the young man was totally
unaware of the Lawrence.
He had diplomatic immunity,
so they simply let him go,
but not all of the wind in the Mongolian
empire where there for the men's
entertainments,
Marco Polo witnessed Kublai Khan's knees.
Princess could a union battle for her
right to choose their own husbands.
She set out to challenge that if any
man could defeat her in wrestling,
they would win a hand in
marriage. However, no one
was ever able to defeat her.
Ng acquired a massive
fleet of 10,000 horses.
She was allowed to remain unmarried and
fought alongside a father and battle
even without polos helped
keep her memory alive.
Could a human story was so incredible
that it has been passed down by word of
mouth in China for hundreds of years.
It's Colin's believed that the polos
would have been afraid of what would have
happened to them after [inaudible]
Khan's death. Since they were foreigners,
not official citizens of the empire,
they may not have had the same rights
and privileges. Once he passed away.
They claimed that they were homesick
and humbly requested to return to Italy.
The condo, you found them very useful and
at first he didn't want to see them go,
but eventually he relented saying that
they could leave as long as they escorted
a woman named Princess Kaka Chins
and meet her new husband in Persia.
She was also called the blue princess
and she was remembered for her legendary
beauty this time. They did not have to go
through the harsh mountains and desert.
They were able to take and boat departure,
but over 100 people,
they died on the journey.
Only 18 survived,
including the polos and the princess.
By the time he returned to Wesley.
Marco Polo had been gone for 24 years
and he was a bachelor in his forties
during the war between Genoa and Venice,
Marco Polo was arrested and the government
illegally seized the majority of his
wealth that he had
acquired in his time away.
He was able to hide some
of his golden gem stones,
but he was Trudy lucky that
his book was a best seller,
otherwise he may have ended up
broke after all of those years away.
As we mentioned before, mocket, they told
these stories to wrist of cello and yes,
he never describes himself
very much of his personal life.
Throughout the entire book,
Maka Paleo is acting more like a
journalist or a non biased observer.
He pauses no personal judgements,
and d simply explains the things that
he was seeing. In a very matter of fact,
way off to publishing the travels of
Marco Polo, the author got mixed reviews.
Some people congratulated him for his
accomplishments while others accused him
of being a liar.
Many of the stories challenged Christian
beliefs about the outside wells and by
comparison,
the Mongolian Empire seemed superior to
Europe and the number of ways they were
wealthy. They were powerful,
well educated, open minded,
and said the strongest army in the world.
These stories made some Europeans feel
inadequate by comparison and they clung
onto that ethnocentric worldview.
In modern times,
scholars have poured over the original
manuscript of Margaret Polos books and
comparative to details of
ancient Chinese documents.
They were able to confirm nearly
every detail be incorrect,
which proves that he was telling the
truth or the long for the rest of his life
market. Pilate tried to ignore the
haters and he went on living his life.
He got married to a Phoenician noble women
and they had three daughters together
and the records of his
oldest daughter's dowry.
It was documented that he passed on the
golden passport that he received from
the con [inaudible] 24 Marco Polo was on
his deathbed surrounded by his family.
A priest showed up to meet him,
his last rites and the urge to Polo to
confess if he had Trudy lied about his
stories as a way of convincing his soul,
his dying words,
whether it's the only told a fraction
of all the stories about his amazing
experiences, and if he had given
away all of the stories in the book,
it would blow everyone's minds and no one
would have believed to many way as the
years went on, there would be several
new additions of market ponos books.
Priests rewrote his stories with a
Christian slant so that they could bolster
Europe superiority.
They highlighted session stories like
the women in Tibet as examples of the
sinfulness and depravity.
They still could not stand the idea
that China was just somehow better than
Europe.
Unfortunately,
the future generations would see this
altered manuscripts and take it as a sign
that white people needed to reform it.
Foreign natives with Christianity,
future explorers like Christopher
Columbus used the salted Veshon of mocket
paradise book as a guide for his own
journey. However, the often got it wrong,
believing that they had landed in an
entirely different country without the
ability to speak the language.
Columbus assumes that he had landed in
India and immediately set out to enslave
the native people.
They called an eye as the
Lens for conquest and greed
rather than attempting to
assimilate or understands the native
American language and culture.
Now people love the story of Marco Polo,
but no one truly knows
what he looks like there.
Are there any artists interpretations
of how they imagined him even though he
had so many stories to tell?
We knew very little about the actual man.
We don't even really know what
he did on a day to day basis,
so anything about his,
despite the fact that we know so
little about who he truly was,
he is still considered to be one of
the most admired people in history,
not just for his discoveries,
but because he lived his
life to the fullest extent.
He was able to experience seeing a new
world that was unlike anything that
Europe had ever seen before,
and he became the real life hero of
every story about that one special person
who is invited to a magical wells.
And that in a way is
what dreams are made of.
So I really hope you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week. Also,
if you think of something
else to watch right now,
why not check out my other
channel called today,
I found out you'll find a link to that
on the screen now as well as below this
video. And as always,
thank you for watching.